mais grâce à ses très bonnes à tout le
monde qu'ils écoutent du français
finalement c'est mon album qui se vend
ailleurs en europe grâce à cette petite
phrase en anglais
je pense que au contraire c c'est une
victoire pour la francophonie
j'ai décroché là je suis à vous savez
pas c'est un truc là nelson qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
il faudrait peut-être ap le répéter
parce que le cul
[Applaudissements]
se trouve que les deux chansons vous
avez diffusé sont les seuls deux que je
sais quoi d'autre celui qui me rend
celle qui me rend fort
je voudrais seulement celui dangereuse 1
je te chercherait comme la mélodie de ma
chanson c'est très poétique
[Applaudissements]